elle tient dans ses mains l'avenir de
milliers de lycéens
car dans ces pochettes au plastique
opaque se trouvent les sujets du
baccalauréat 2010 9 sur lesquels vont
plancher les élèves
si toute la semaine prochaine ils sont
arrivés dans les établissements la
semaine passée et mis depuis dans un
coffre fort et ultra sécurisé impossible
d'en savoir la teneur recevons des
enveloppes qui sont scellés qui sont à
déchirables est complètement opaque
donc il ya un système de sécurité une
sécurisation qui se veut maximale on n'a
pas le droit désolé on ne veut pas les
voir ils sont
ils sont triés ils sont prêts pour la
distribution si les candidats ont
déserté le lycée depuis mercredi pour
réviser dans les salles ans s'active
pour préparer l'examen c'est morissette
qui est aux manettes 20e bac à son actif
elle doit préparer une vingtaine de
salles pour plus de 200 élèves et tout
est bien réglé
nous avons fixé le nombre d'élèves pas
trop élevés dans chaque salle 1 pour que
les îles soient dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
donc nous installons des étiquettes par
ordre alphabétique
et puis nous installons une copie une
copie de battre des feuilles de
brouillon on alterne les couleurs pour
éviter d éventuellement les éventuels
tricheurs et veillez bien seule
nouveauté l'établissement va tester
cette année la numérisation de quelques
copies pour la correction avec un gain
de temps et de sécurité
reste enfin à gérer l'éventuelle grève
de surveillants lundi avec d'autres
personnels administratifs mobilisés
[Musique]